safety there is a safety concern
confrontations in canada's capital as
police are given new powers to charge
truckers who have held firm for nearly
three weeks
trucks and protesters have shut down
these streets outside parliament in
downtown ottawa
as well as disrupting businesses and
cross-border trade with the us
which one enshrines our inalienable
rights as citizens so we have you know
the right right to free speech freedom
of assembly freedom to move freedom to
do this
canadian truckers calling themselves the
freedom convoy had gathered to make a
stand against rule the required truckers
to be vaccinated to cross the u.s
canadian border
they were later joined by other
protesters many from far-right groups
on thursday police moved in to arrest
the leaders chris barber filmed here and
tamara lynch
prime minister justin trudeau has
invoked the emergencies act which gives
powers to declare the blockade illegal
arrest drivers freeze bank accounts and
suspend licenses
on monday
as we entered the third week of illegal
blockades and occupations
the federal government
invoked the emergencies act
we did it to protect families and small
businesses to protect jobs
and the economy
we did it because the situation
could not be dealt with under any other
law in canada
police have secured a parameter around
the protests in the downtown core
they've handed these orders to truckers
leave or face charges
it's just a fake paper
so it says here you must leave the area
now
but and the
warning that anyone blocking streets or
assisting others in the blocking of the
streets are committing a criminal
offense
and you might be arrested i'm not afraid
to be arrested as much as it uh
time it's going to take to get
everything straightened out and back to
work
normal
i mean if they arrest me then i go back
to work eventually once it's all sorted
out
if they don't want to come to the table
and talk
i stay here and i'm not working anyway
so
we'll see where it goes
the movement has captured the world's
attention but the canadian truckers
association says it doesn't represent
the majority of drivers who are
vaccinated and working hard to ensure
trade continues
police now want to end this peacefully
but even with threats many truckers
remain defiant
laura burden manly al jazeera